[Musique]
bonjour
vous êtes vraiment nombreux je me
présente je suis votre professeur de
physique
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans ce
cours de physique
alors avant de commencer je vais
vérifier les présents ou mais je vois au
premier rang des visages bien connus ils
iront loin en physique cela
et puis au fond des élèves un peu plus
timides peut-être ou qui se sentent
perdus en physique quel dommage et
j'imagine que vous vous disposez
autrement dans d'autres classes
puisque nous sommes en début d'année je
vais vous poser une première question
quelles sont vos attentes pour ce cours
de physique
j'imagine que vous vous attendez à
quelque chose de classique je peux le
faire je sais le faire je peux vous
parler des heures et des heures du monde
merveilleux des sciences des mouvements
de la lumière de la structure de l'atome
et puis à vous de prendre note de
m'écouter de rentrer chez vous d'étudier
de mémoriser de restituer d'apprendre
on se retrouve en classe on fait les
exercices je réponds à vos questions
vous retournez chez vous vous mémorisez
vous ingurgitez vous digérez vous
revenez je vous fais des tests vous avez
des bonnes notes j'imagine que c'est à
cela que vous vous attendez
et bien moi je vous propose quelque
chose de différent
ça sera pas une classe inversée bien que
c'est une méthode pédagogiquement active
et intéressante vous connaissez le
principe on fait le cours à la maison
les exercices en classe
moi je vous propose une nouvelle idée
cette idée s'appelle collaborer pour le
succès
en quelques mots construisons ensemble
le succès de tous
le professeur n'est plus le seul à
proposer
je vais vous demander de construire avec
moi le cours donc à vous de proposer de
chercher des parties de cours de faire
des résumés de rédiger de valider de
trier l'information de partager entre
vous bref on construit ensemble
je vais essayer de préciser mon idée
parce que je vois des visages inquiets
surtout au premier rang
dans cette stratégie je vais vous
proposer une méthode et notamment je
vais vous répartir en équipe
dès l'équipe des équipes construites sur
des critères
d'affinités de niveau de points forts de
points faibles de façon de travailler de
façon de s'organiser
selon vos besoins vous attendent et à
vous
de vous organiser de vous répartir les
tâches de vous répartir les rôles on va
construire ensemble le succès de tous
alors pour l'examen certains me diront
où là où on va faire pour l'examen je
vous rassure je continue à préparer
l'examen
mais je vous demanderai de contribuer au
reste du cours autrement dit de faire le
travail si on pousse l'idée un peu loin
vous faites tout je ne fais plus rien
dans ces exemples ces idées je vais vous
proposer de travailler selon la méthode
des tableaux tournants donc vous serez
répartis en équipe 5 minutes face à un
tableau pour répondre à une question une
problématique
amenée par la classe
et là au bout de 5 minutes une rotation
vous changez de tableau vous découvrez
le travail d'un autre groupe à vous de
l'enrichir de le modifier de le
poursuivre
au bout de trois ou quatre rotations on
se retrouve tous ensemble autour d'un
tableau qu'on aura choisi afin de
construire ensemble la réponse à la
problématique
autre exemple de ce que je peux vous
demander c'est la méthode de la
correction collaborative
alors dans cette méthode vous devez
personne ressource
c'est à dire que vous vous mettez à
disposition de la classe
après avoir validé votre réponse le
professeur vous déclare comme ressources
au même titre que lui-même et vous vous
mettez à disposition vous allez aider ce
qui demande votre aide pour essayer de
les guider dans la résolution d'un
problème sans leur donner bien sûr la
réponse toute faite c'est une espèce de
tutorat temporaire et évolutif
bien évidemment je vais pas vous laisser
seul je vais vous proposer une méthode
et dans cette méthode je vous proposerai
par exemple un plan de travail un plan
de travail en trois parcours avec un
parcours que j'appelle des couvreur un
parcours explorateur et un parcours
chercheur
à vous de vous positionner dans ce
parcours à votre rythme selon vos
besoins grâce au travail de tous on va
arriver tous au même objectif
alors deuxième question
est-ce que parmi vous
il y a des élèves intéressés pour tenter
cette aventure avec moi en physique
cette année
vous pouvez juste lever la main il n'y a
pas de piège
super bon je vois
S4 toujours volontaire merci
donc ici cette idée
collaborée pour le succès est en train
de germer dans une petite équipe de
professeurs de l'école qui réfléchissent
qui propose des stratégies des idées
qui essaient de mettre en place des
ressources qui établissent des points
forts des points faibles et qui vont
essayer de mettre en action tout ça pour
essayer d'évoluer vers la mise en œuvre
de cette méthode
si je résume un peu la classe devient
comme une entreprise
les équipes collaborent entre elles
chaque équipe ayant un morceau du puzzle
à construire et à amener
chaque équipe ayant un rôle chacun
devant trouver sa place peu importe son
niveau ses projets peu importe s'il a un
peu plus de difficulté s'il est
différent s'il a des besoins spécifiques
il trouvera sa place dans ce processus
puisqu'on parle d'une construction
commune
la classe devient donc comme une petite
entreprise un laboratoire de fabrication
un FabLab
puisque vous allez fabriquer vous allez
être actif et bien vous ne serez plus
simplement évaluer sur vos connaissances
puisqu'on aura besoin de VOUS
savoir-faire et de vous savoir être donc
vous serez évalué sur vos compétences
de quelles compétences je parle et bien
des compétences pour s'organiser pour
planifier des compétences pour trier
choisir des informations communiquer des
compétences autour de la production
des compétences autour de
l'expérimentation bref de rentrer dans
une démarche globale où vous allez
prendre un problème l'analyser raisonner
expérimenter
globalement la métacompétence au dessus
de tout ça c'est la compétence d'esprit
d'entreprise c'est votre esprit
d'entreprise que nous allons mettre en
œuvre et que nous allons évaluer
dans cette démarche et bien comme dans
toute démarche de projet il faudra bien
évidemment recueillir le point de vue
des principaux acteurs et pour commencer
le point de vue des élèves
puisqu'on va leur demander de collaborer
une des premières choses à faire c'est
de leur demander si ils savent ce que
signifie collaborer
et bien il faudra donc envisager
probablement des temps de formation pour
les élèves
et ensuite de toujours être à leur
écoute quelles sont leurs attentes quels
sont leurs besoins
et donc de recueillir
régulièrement leur point de vue essayez
de savoir un petit peu où il se situe si
chacun se sent bien dans le processus si
chacun se sent gagnant dans ce processus
si tout le monde est à l'aise enfin bref
si nous sommes dans l'inclusion de tous
et si chacun a bien un rôle à jouer dans
ce dispositif
point de vue des élèves c'est peut-être
avec les élèves qui sont ce qu'on
appelle des bons élèves qu'il faudra
être attentif en effet pourquoi changer
quelque chose pour quelqu'un pour lequel
tout va bien
donc pour les bons élèves il faudra
faire attention bien sûr
à ce que ce processus leur permet de
poursuivre leur évolution et bien
évidemment
à leur montrer
ce qu'ils ont à gagner et notamment en
termes de compétences
autre point de vue important le point de
vue des professeurs
ceci nécessite bien évidemment un
travail d'équipe une réflexion
pédagogique d'équipe et puisque je viens
de le dire nous devons être à l'écoute
des élèves et bien il faudra qu'il se
mette
à l'écoute des besoins des attentes
qu'ils soient donc flexibles qu'ils
puissent s'adapter aux besoins de la
classe on crée une espèce de communauté
pédagogique réactive et ouverte sur la
classe
autre point de vue important
c'est celui des partenaires
pour le point de vue des partenaires
je pense au futur écoles qui vont
accueillir nos élèves les universités
par exemple
est-ce qu'ils verront une différence
serait donc intéressant de garder
contact avec les anciens élèves pour
savoir comment il se situe dans leur
poursuite d'études
nous avons aussi un recueillir le point
de vue des professionnels qui
accueillent nos élèves dans le stage en
entreprise la works expérience ou lors
de différents concours les Olympiades
les concours des locquence est-ce que
ces professionnels voient une évolution
des compétences de nos élèves
enfin différents points de vue celui des
parents c'est là qu'on peut être le plus
surpris bon en effet on sait qu'ils sont
souvent inquiets pour l'avenir et le
bien-être de leurs enfants c'est bien
normal
et donc il faudra là aussi être dans un
processus de communication mais on peut
faire le pari que si on arrive à montrer
que l'école permet à chacun
de trouver sa place à chacun de prendre
confiance
à chacun de gagner en compétence de se
sentir valorisé par des certifications
diverses pas simplement par un bulletin
et bien on peut faire le pari que les
élèves se sentiront mieux
plus confiant en eux plus confiant à
l'avenir avec l'envie d'aller plus loin
après leur passage dans notre école
il faudra donc rester dans la
communication c'est-à-dire dans un
processus de confiance le maître mot
c'est bien évidemment la confiance que
nous devons tous avoir les uns envers
les autres
tout cela fait appel à un processus en
sorte d'innovation
et l'innovation c'est le fruit de la
créativité donc dans ce dispositif il
faut laisser les différents acteurs
la possibilité d'être créatif leur
laisser le temps
d'imaginer des situations de proposer
des visions des inspirations bref
d'expérimenter en tout état de cause et
en connaissance de ce principe
l'innovation c'est donc quelque chose
qui est important mais le vrai challenge
de l'innovation c'est pas forcément
d'aller vers du nouveau c'est plutôt
d'articuler l'ancien avec le nouveau
c'est à dire que nous n'allons pas tout
casser pour faire quelque chose d'autre
il faut conserver des choses qui
marchent par exemple des moments de
cours il y aura toujours des moments de
cours il y aura toujours des moments où
il faudra apprendre les tables de
multiplication mais on peut imaginer que
si ces processus arrivent au moment où
un groupe une classe en a besoin alors
les élèves qui ont besoin de cette
information l'utiliseront et la
mémoriserons bien mieux que si elle
tombe juste pour préparer un test
cette idée d'innovation ne peut se faire
que si elle repose sur des piliers forts
et sur cette image et bien on résume un
petit peu tout ce process avec un plan
d'action qui est en train de germer dans
la tête d'une petite équipe
la collaboration qui est le maître mot
et qui permet de développer beaucoup de
valeurs qui sont pas simplement des
valeurs
liées à la connaissance mais aussi des
valeurs sociales le respect des uns des
autres respecter des différences
respecter des opinions différentes
collaborer c'est savoir se mettre
à disposition d'un collectif savoir
apporter quelque chose dans le collectif
et faire en sorte que chacun puisse
apporter une pierre à l'édifice
notre petite étoile mais si bien sûr la
réussite de chacun de nos élèves
et puis dans ce processus et bien il
faut oser il faut inventer donc il ne
faut pas avoir peur de s'exposer à des
échecs et puis s'il y a des échecs nous
sommes en équipe
les équipes
par un processus d'intelligence
collective proposeront des solutions que
nous pourrons ensuite essayer
le but de tout ça étant d'aller vers la
confiance en soi
d'améliorer la réussite de tous et la
réussite aussi bien au niveau des études
que au niveau bien sûr professionnel
futur
il s'agit donc d'un vrai défi mais avant
honte testons exploitons et c'est ce que
je vous propose de tester cette année en
physique
pour finir je citerai
deux personnes un scientifique Lavoisier
qui a dit et vous le savez bien au cours
d'un processus chimique rien ne se perd
rien de secret tout se transforme et
bien pourquoi pas tester avec la
pédagogie
et enfin Michel Serres qui est un
historien des sciences qui a dit que le
but de l'instruction c'est la fin de
l'instruction c'est-à-dire le début de
l'invention
merci
[Applaudissements]